auf dem weg nach schottland in den
wilden norden des vereinigten
königreichs noch ist hier keine grenze
noch ist schottland ein teil
großbritanniens
aber das könnte sich ändern der ruf nach
unabhängigkeit wird immer lauter
seitdem rexit den so viele schotten
nicht gewollt haben aber will wirklich
die mehrheit der schotten den bruch mit
england kann es sein dass schottland
bald eine souveräne nation wird
[Musik]
direkt an der grenze treffe ich tom
fairfax dem hier ein großes stück land
gehört tom ist halb schotte halb
engländer
letzten umfragen zufolge will mehr als
die hälfte der schotten ausbrechen aus
dem königreich tom fairfax hält das für
romantischen unsinn
er nimmt mich mit auf den höchsten punkt
seiner ländereien dahin wo nach der
unabhängigkeit eine mögliche grenze
verlaufen wurde ist das hier schon nein
das ist noch england hier aber da drüben
ist schottland und wenn du einen unfall
hast ist das nächste notfall krankenhaus
in england ca 50 meilen von hier
es ist einfach ein land das ist in
schottland mein hausarzt in england wir
verlieren als einwand doch nichts von
der schottischen magie außerdem hatte
schottland seine besten zeiten als teil
von großbritannien
schottland gehört immerhin seit 1707 zu
england diese beiden länder jetzt nach
mehr als 300 jahren wieder auseinander
zu reißen findet tom einfach unnötig und
viel zu kompliziert
wir wissen ja auch noch gar nicht wie
das dann geregelt wäre im detail aber
überlegen sie mal wie schwierig das beim
black silver und beim exit gab es ja
schon so etwas wie eine grenze zu europa
vorher england und schottland aber sind
so viel stärker miteinander verwoben
was das für eine energie kosten würde
das wieder zu entflechten
unglaublich
das wäre ein zweiter block sind ein
schock so sehen das alle so hier in der
grenzregion
wir fahren nach konz trier den ersten
ort direkt hinter der grenze
die meisten die ich hier frage ob sie
für die schottische unabhängigkeit sind
sehen das so wie er hier manche leute
denken immer alles wäre besser wenn es
nur anlass ist aber ich finde nicht dass
ist das risiko wert ist
der ladenbesitzer direkt gegenüber ist
engländer aber lebt hier seit er denken
kann wie so viele hier erhitzt die
gemüter
aber die vernunft mit hoffentlich siegen
finanziell ist das doch so viel besser
zusammen ein land zu bleiben
uns geht es einfach besser zusammen gibt
es denn überhaupt jemanden coldstream
der für die unabhängigkeit ist ihm fällt
nach einigem nachdenken nur ein einziger
ein und gibt mir seine nummer donald
nach wird der lokale abgeordnete der
schottischen nationalpartei der ist froh
mein eindruck zurecht zu rücken
sie sind einer der ganz wenigen hier der
für die unabhängigkeit ist
nein ich bin einer von mindestens 30
hier in der gegend
ich denke schottland ist auf keinen fall
stärker im verbunden mit england wir
sind eine der letzten kolonien des
königreichs
ganz so einfach ist das aber nicht seine
partei die schottische nationalpartei
will das zwar unbedingt aber einem
solchen referendum müsste london
offiziell zustimmen die regierung dort
will das aber nicht
ist trotzdem zuversichtlich da bin ich
ganz sicher
[Musik]
in der grenzregion wären die fans der
unabhängigkeit aber sicher nicht in der
mehrheit
wo sind sie die schotten die dafür sind
ich fahre weiter ins land wo die nähe
zur england keine so große rolle mehr
spielt nach lenkung wo die landschaft
aus riesigen rohren besteht
[Musik]
in schottland gehört das land noch immer
nur ganz wenigen grossgrundbesitzer die
menschen die hier leben dürfen diese
ländereien oft nicht einmal betreten
innenraum haben die bewohner jetzt die
initiative dagegen ergriffen und sind
wild entschlossen das bislang undenkbare
in die tat umzusetzen
sie kaufen die moore rund um ihre kleine
stadt dem herzog von bei knapp um das
land für alle zugänglich zu machen
mary und margit waren von anfang an das
vor zwei jahren schlug die nachricht der
herzog wolle verkaufen wie eine bombe in
länger ein
aber er wollte drei millionen pfund für
das moor viel geld für die kleine
gemeinde
wir haben bis zum letzten moment
gezittert es war sehr eng und erst in
den letzten 48 stunden kam dann doch
noch ein paar leute dazu die uns
gerettet
ein couragiertes du das wie sich
herausstellt auch vor den mühen der
schottischen unabhängigkeit keine
sekunde zurückschrecken würde
natürlich können wir das schaffen und
wir waren ja auch einmal ein eigenes
land vor einigen jahrhunderten
wir schotten sind einfach sehr
unabhängige menschen die sich ungern
etwas vorschreiben lassen
das ist der kern unserer identität erst
einmal aber erobern sie sich jetzt das
moor vor ihrer haustür
[Musik]
über 2.000 hektar land das bislang
kommerziell für moroni akten genutzt
wurde
sie wollen es jetzt wieder in den
naturzustand versetzt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
helfen sollen ihnen dabei volontäre wie
harris die jüngst in ihrer gruppe wird
jetzt tatsächlich unser land sein
unser und das macht mich glücklich
vor allem für die nächste generation wie
käme ich möchte vor allem die torfmoore
wiederherstellen denn die binden sehr
viel kohlendioxid und das hilft gegen
den klimawandel ein so großes thema für
unsere zukunft eine riesige aufgabe die
noch vor ihnen liegt und mit der sie
beginnen wollen wenn der graf von betrug
den kaufvertrag unterschreibt der ihnen
übrigens den vollen marktpreis berechnet
hat und für uns nicht zu sprechen war
weil er sich auf einem seiner vielen
land schlösser um seine restlichen
besitztümer kümmern musste
aber sein manager hatte zehn minuten für
uns warum sie das moor überhaupt
verkauft haben solche großen ländereien
zu besitzen es mit kosten verbunden das
ist für uns hauptsächlich ein business
insofern hoffen wir dass die gemeinde
das jetzt auch hinbekommt und genug
ideen hat um das ganze finanziell auch
halten zu können
man brauchte eben cash und war nicht
unglücklich dass moore so leicht und gut
los zu werden
[Musik]
nicht alle in weinheim waren deshalb
anfangs begeistert über margaret und
marys idee wieso eigentlich sollte die
gemeinde einem großgrundbesitzer so viel
geld geben und damit indirekt alte
feudale verhältnisse anerkennen
eigentlich haben diese adligen sich das
land dann als einfach genommen aber
recht nicht gehörten nun mal jetzt und
wir konnten es ja nicht einfach wieder
zurück steht das moor erfolgreich zu
verwalten wird nicht einfach aber wer
nichts wagt der gewinnt auch nicht sagen
sie mir zum abschied und so sei das im
übrigen auch mit der schottischen
unabhängigkeit
[Musik]
das ziel ein umweltgerechtes land zu
gründen
treibt viele hier um die schottlands
unabhängigkeit wollen
in glasgow findet im november die
nächste große un klimakonferenz statt
ein passender standort denn die schotten
sind umweltbewusst schon jetzt beziehen
sie 90 prozent ihrer stromversorgung aus
erneuerbarer energie
unter dieser autobahnbrücke sind wir mit
viel glas friedens verabredet auf dieser
brachfläche planen sie zum klimagipfel
im november ein riesenprojekt bäume
wollen sie hier pflanzen bilden gärten
anlegen infos zum klimawandel mit
streetart und viel musik begleiten
[Musik]
ein spielplatz für eine bessere welt und
eine initiative die spontan entstand
ohne anleitung der stadt das typisch
schottisch ist der typisch glasgow
vielleicht wir morgen nicht bis uns
jemand etwas sagt wir nehmen die sachen
selbst ja wir ergreifen immer gerne
selbst die initiative
das ist schon sehr schade
wir wollen unser eigenes ding machen uns
selbst bestimmen
sie alle hier wollen deshalb auch
unabhängig werden von england was
typisch ist für ihre generation fast
drei viertel der unter 35 jährigen
schotten will ganz klar den bruch mit
ländern
wir schauten haben noch nie für die
historischen england gestellt wir sind
eine so viel linkere sozial
demokratische gesellschaft und dennoch
bekommen wir jedes mal sich regierungen
die wir gewählt haben und finanziell
wäre die unabhängigkeit auch gar kein
problem wir haben so viel wasser und
windenergie
wir können das locker alleine stemmen
und zu sagen wir stünden allein
schlechter da ist ja auch unser guck dir
zum beispiel die fischer an
die gehen gerade deshalb alle pleite
mittelfristig wäre es deshalb viel
besser unabhängig zu werden
auf sich allein gestellt könnten sie
wieder der eu beitreten und in brig set
hier oben rückgängig machen ich fahre
nach katyn ein schottisches fischerdorf
wenn sie dort tatsächlich vom rexit so
getroffen wurden wäre die unabhängigkeit
für sie jetzt der ausweg
sonnenaufgang in der kleinen hafenstadt
[Musik]
eigentlich ist das der moment in dem
thema zu vollem leben erwacht heute
morgen aber sie hat nur ein einziges
schiff aufs meer
für die meisten fischer scheint sich das
rausfahren seit dem brett tatsächlich
nicht mehr zu lohnen ein eigentor sagen
viele
denn die meisten fischer hier haben für
den exit gestimmt weil sie sich davon
mehr fang rechte erhofften auch kenny
hat das geglaubt wie er mir gleich zu
beginn sagt wie fühlt er sich jetzt
damit
wir sind glücklich natürlich nicht aber
ihr könnt uns auch nicht die schuld
geben weil wir für den exit waren die
regierung in london muss da jetzt
wirklich etwas unternehmen sie sagen
immer das spiel sich noch ein aber das
ist nicht so es ist viel schlimmer
besonders schlimm hat es die fischer
getroffen die frische muscheln und
schalentiere in die eu exportiert haben
waren die schlecht werden wenn sie durch
die neuen kontrollen zu lange an der
grenze fest hängen und die sie deshalb
jetzt nicht mehr so einfach in die eu
exportieren können
das hier sind ganz frische gerade erste
mutschel 1a qualität die gegen sonst in
die eu jetzt zerschlagen wir sie und
exportieren das fleisch als titulare
damit verlieren wir 60 prozent an wert
nimmt uns mit zu seinem chef jamie der
früher selber einmal fischer war erst
vor einem jahr hat er sich selbstständig
gemacht als exporteur
jetzt weiß er nicht mehr wie lange er
seine fünf angestellten überhaupt noch
bezahlen kann
vor dem referendum waren all diese
politiker hier an unseren helfen auf
stimmenfang
jetzt kommt hier keiner mehr hoch jetzt
versuchen sie der eu die schuld in die
schuhe zu schieben
aber das ist die londoner regierung die
diesen deal verbrochen hat
sein problem es gibt zwar ein braig
citydeal und deshalb keine direkten
server auf seine waren aber dennoch jede
menge neuer bürokratie vor allem
hunderte von formularen die jamies
buchhalterin oft genauso wenig versteht
wie er es ist total verrückt
es ist komplizierter als wenn wir nach
china exportieren
so makaber es ist sogar noch viel
schlimmer als das was das kostet uns
vorher gesagt dass wir zwölf prozent
mehr um kosten haben werden
exit diese politiker sollten sich
schämen
das ist einfach widerwärtig
george ist ähnlich enttäuscht über den
dreck cit zumal er nicht weiß wie lange
noch arbeit haben wird ich bin bitter
und ich bereue mein votum dafür
sie haben uns verraten und verkauft und
ich sehe keinen ausweg mehr wäre die
unabhängigkeit ein ausweg um dann wieder
zu treten
sie haben uns so oft belogen keiner
traut hier niemanden mehr
sie haben uns sachen versprochen und
nichts ist passiert also würden sie
nicht für die unabhängigkeit stimmen im
moment nicht liegt laut keine mehr
wenn aber selbst sie nicht für die
unabhängigkeit stimmen wollen wer tut
das dann hinter oben auf dem hügel über
dem hafen treffe ich die rag und beide
glühende anhänger über die fischer unter
ihnen nur den kopf schütteln
vielleicht müssen einige erstmal spüren
was sie da angerichtet haben und sehen
was das für sie bedeutet
vielleicht brauchen sie dass niemand von
uns will das aber vielleicht müssen sie
es am eigenen leib spüren
tabat sehe jetzt schweren zeiten
entgegen der unabhängigkeit werde das
neuen aufschwung geben fängst du das so
wenn die kommune es gibt jetzt so viele
menschen hier die einfach gesehen haben
wie sie von london belogen worden
die unterstützung für die unabhängigkeit
ist deshalb nur größer geworden mexiko
ich glaube es ist
wir sind europäer schottland war immer
eine europäische nation
wir haben mit euch gehandelt unsere
kinder 1 euro unis in deutschland
geschickt wir können doch jetzt nicht
plötzlich andere leute wäre und deshalb
müssen wir zurück in die eu
vor allem die jungen wollen das
unbedingt ich hoffe dass ich das noch
erlebe aber wenn nicht es wird passieren
man kann doch eine nation nicht auf
dauer gegen ihren willen festhalten sie
beide sind sich da ganz sicher aber
können ihre argumente auch die fischer
unten im hafen überzeugen
jamie der ernsthaft um seine firma
fürchtet ist zumindest ins nachdenken
gekommen bist du viel mehr informationen
wenn wir der eu wieder beitreten würden
gut aber würde das heißen dass diese
ganze bürokratie papierkram diese
formulare wirklich wieder aufhören diese
infos hätte ich diesmal gern vorher
gehabt ihn humor
ich bräuchte genaue fakten bevor wir
hier überhaupt jemals wieder für
irgendwas stimmen sie haben einfach
jedes vertrauen verloren und glauben
vorerst niemandem mehr schon gar nicht
denen die ihnen einen weiteren wilden
aufbruch ins ungewisse versprechen
[Musik]
von tabak an der westküste hoch in die
highlands den wilden norden schottlands
der so reich an natürlichen ressourcen
ist energie die in zukunft immer
wichtiger wird gibt es hier im überfluss
sonne wasser und vor allem den wind
[Musik]
direkt am ufer von loch ness treffen wir
jeremy leggett vor einem jahr hat er
hier ein großes stück land gekauft
er will es renaturieren und das heißt
erst einmal bäume fällen der nadelbäume
wie diese gehörten hier nie hin und
zerstören das empfindliche ökologische
gleichgewicht der erfolgreiche
unternehmer und ehemalige greenpeace
aktivist hat sich viel vorgenommen
das land rund um loch ness ist
ausgelaugt durch jahrzehntelange über
nutzer mit einem team junger biologen
und förster will er das jetzt ändern
einerseits die böden regenerieren und
dann ökologisch nachhaltige häuser bauen
die sein projekt finanzieren sollen
im moment wird das land nur für freizeit
jacken genutzt werden hühner am himmel
aber ich träume davon dieses land auf
sanfte grüne art kommerziell erfolgreich
zu machen und damit andere zu überzeugen
dass man auch so geld verdienen kann
ihr hauptziel dabei eine umgebung
herzustellen in der auch die böden
wieder dazu beitragen den klimawandel
aufzuhalten
viele wissen nicht dass die böden
entscheiden sind wenn der kohlenstoff
binden willst gucken wir auf das was
oberhalb der erde passiert und vergessen
dass gesunde löhnen ebenfalls für co2
jeremy leggett ist engländer anders als
viele die hier ganze landstriche
aufkaufen will er das land nach seinem
tod über eine stiftung an die schotten
zurückgehen
eine gesellschaft in der sich so viel
wohler fühlt als unter engländern in
schotten und engländer sind wie feuer
und wasser
sie schoben wollen migranten helfen sich
um irland zu kümmern
das totale gegenteil von england wo du
einen haufen rechter nationalisten hast
die fremden hierher gezogen
würde er dann auch den nächsten schritt
mitgehen schottland ganz von england
abzukoppeln
im prinzip ja erklärt er mir ist so
reich an rohstoffen und die schotten
könnten dann eigene gesetze und finanz
regeln für eine ökologischere wirtschaft
machen
da wäre eine bessere gesellschaft sehr
schnell möglich
ich hätte mehr angst
eine stunde weiter nördlich liegt das
größte hochmoor europas das flow country
dass ich bis an die nördlichste spitze
schottlands zieht
märgen bauland ist wild hüterin hier
ihre hauptaufgabe die hirsche im auge zu
behalten und sie auch immer wieder zu
schießen bevor sie hierher kam war sie
vegetarierin ein tier zu töten war ja
eigentlich fremd aber die hirsche
zerstören die wertvollen moore wenn sie
zu zahlreich werden und so gewöhnten
sich da es war seltsam von meinem
erstmal habe ich mich vorher gefragt
werde ich voller adrenalin sein werde
ich wein aber dann war es überraschend
einfach
es fühlte sich einfach richtig an und
ich war zufrieden das ist in meiner
verantwortung wahr dass vernünftig zu
machen moore wie im flow country sind
einzigartig aus toten pflanzenresten ist
hier über tausende von jahren eine
landschaft gewachsen die millionen
tonnen von co2 in der tiefe verwahrt
wenn diese moss pflanzen hier wachsen
ziehen sie kohlendioxid aus der
atmosphäre und kapsel das mit sich im
boden ein
ich zeige euch das mal
so sieht sie aus wie sie verändert die
atmosphäre um sich selbst zu ernähren
hier ist es gerade nicht so tief dass
diese dürften pro jahr nur um einen
millimeter wachsen dann weißt du wie
viele tausende von jahren die erde hier
alt ist es gibt stellen hier da ist das
torfmoor vier bis fünf meter tief
[Musik]
märgen liebt die freiheit hier draußen
aber sie ist auch eine zutiefst
nüchterne frau braveheart ist nicht ihr
job
die schottische unabhängigkeit ist ihr
als idee viel zu romantisch käme es in
der nächsten zeit zu einem referendum
sieg würde nicht unbedingt dafür stimmen
ich wollte dafür viel mehr information
ich würde nicht blind für soetwas
stimmen guck dir das chaos hat den
praxis und wir waren nur 40 jahre in der
eu schottland und england aber waren
hunderte von ja wie soll das praktisch
gehen
ein weiteres politisches abenteuer
braucht morgen nach dem break sieht
nicht ein unabhängiges schottland wäre
für sie nur der nächste aufbruch ins
ungewisse
aber wäre die unabhängigkeit finanziell
wirklich so riskant
weiter nach aber die
[Musik]
das öl vor der schottischen küste war
als die schotten zuletzt über ihre
unabhängigkeit abstimmen
das zentrale argument der befürworter
wenn man die einnahmen nicht mehr mit
england teilen müsse sei schottland ein
reiches land
seitdem aber hat sich einiges geändert
die ölpreise sind eingebrochen und die
ölvorkommen vor der küste sind weit
geringer als man damals dachte ich
besucher den bürgermeister der mitten im
zentrum in einem echten palast roth auch
panik crockett hat keine lust auf das
abenteuer unabhängigkeit denn alba dean
war schon immer eine reiche stadt
erklärt er mir und das solle bitte so
bleiben wir haben mehr millionäre als
jeder andere gegend in großbritannien
sie sind 30 hat mit vielen großen firma
barney crockett hat sich hochgearbeitet
aus echte armut die es neben dem
reichtum mir auch immer gab der
niedergang der schottischen ölindustrie
mache die unabhängigkeit jetzt schlicht
unmöglich sagt er
tags tk industrie wo der steuern wie aus
der ölindustrie kommen werden und bei
unseren sitzen referendum hat sich alles
darum gedreht wie man diese öl steuern
demnächst ausgehen würde
aber dieses irgendwie alt wird es nicht
mehr geben
also ist die frage wird die schottische
regierung dann die steuern erhöhen
fast 60 prozent haben hier deshalb 2014
für den verbleib im königreich gestimmt
vor allem für die alteingesessenen
amazoniens ist ein schottischer
alleingang schlicht unvorstellbar wir
treffen jim allen einen der
erfolgreichsten unternehmer in aberdeen
seine millionen hat er mit bojen für
ölplattformen gemacht neuerdings
investiert er auch in die windindustrie
plastik schutzhüllen für offshore
windräder könnten die erneuerbaren
energien die unabhängigkeit nicht doch
noch möglich machen frage ich ihn ende
bundes unabhängigkeit nein das wäre das
schlimmste was dem land passieren könnte
warum weil sie es sich nicht leisten
können
die schottischen nationalisten jammern
immer über die regierung in london und
dann wollen sie doch mehr geld von und
unser größter kunde ist um england das
ist einfach verrückt und sie lügen
der bürgermeister hat uns gesagt dass
dann die steuern steigen würden ist das
auch ihre angst ja klar das ist meine
größte sorge ob ich will oder nicht ich
müsste dann hier oben steuern zahlen ich
habe deshalb schon beim letzten mal eine
menge geld fließen lassen um das zu
verhindern
und das würde ich es wieder tun germain
und barney crockett der bürgermeister
sind alte freund und noch haben sie das
heft in der hand in der badi falls die
stimmung aber doch noch in richtung
unabhängigkeit kippen sollte
dann wissen sie genau was zu tun ist
st argumentieren und praktischen
probleme hinweisen und würden wir denn
dann haben können wenn noch gezahlt
werden
und ich glaube das wird die leute schon
von allein zur vernunft bringen
schottland wird das nicht bekommen weil
es nicht gut ist für schottland das
sieht mindestens die hälfte der schotten
vollkommen anders
auf dem weg nach edinburgh treffe ich
einige der jes biker eine gruppe von
mehreren hundert motorrad fans die seit
jahren im ganzen land unterwegs sind und
für die unabhängigkeit zu werben sind
ihre träume jetzt geplatzt sei das öl
das alles nicht mehr finanzieren kann
das gilt auch hier nicht allein um das
öl wir haben so viele andere
möglichkeiten uns zu finanzieren die
andere seite will uns einfach immer nur
kleine ihr seid so arm ist groß geworden
aber das ist nicht so sie wollen sich
abkoppeln von england reisen und aus
schottland ein gerechteres sozialeres
land machen
sie alle sind anhänger der schottischen
nationalpartei wie bei den wahlen am 6
mai mit dem versprechen antritt und
zweites referendum zur unabhängigkeit
abzuhalten und gute chancen hat zu
gewinnen eine partei die links von der
mitte angesiedelt ist ausgeschlossen
er ist ein großer schottischer
nationalismus ist offen für alle
ich nenne die menschen hier gar nicht
mehr schotten ich sage schottlands
menschen
wir haben hier so viele europäer und sie
sind doch ein teil von uns stolz auf
mein land meine flagge aber vor allem
darauf dass wir jeden willkommen heißen
der exit nationalismus der engländer
lehnen sie ab umso mehr ärgert sie dass
london einem zweiten referendum nicht
zustimmen sie sagen dass immer das
verwendung 2014 1 für alle zeiten
gewesen sein soll
aber wir schotten wollen dass selbst
entscheiden in einem land zu sagen dass
es nicht über sich selbst bestimmen darf
das ist doch diktatur hat alles
verändert
selbst die fischer und den bauern die
immer gegen die unabhängigkeit wahren
fangen jetzt an darüber nachzudenken wir
gewinnen dass diesmal keine frage
ich habe geweint als wir das letzte mal
verloren haben
aber diesmal vor glück
für sie ist die frage schon lange nicht
mehr ob sie kommt die unabhängigkeit
sondern nur noch wann sie kommt und mit
ihr ein schottland das wieder der eu
beitritt die reguläre hauptstadt eines
unabhängigen neuen schottland wäre dann
erkennbar wo bereits jetzt das
regionalparlament der schotten seinen
sitz hat und sich zum ärger london
trotz drecks it standhaft weigert die
eu-flagge abzunehmen
ein zeichen dass eu bürger hier weiter
willkommen sind empfinden die europäer
die hier leben das aber selber auch so
ich treffe tanja bültmann eine deutsche
die vor kurzem aus england nach
edinburgh gezogen ist um schottischen
studenten geschichte beizubringen ist
schottland wirklich ein anderes land als
england man muss natürlich immer
aufpassen dass man jetzt keine
stereotypen verbreitet aber die schotten
sind schon an das herzlich und vor allen
dingen der ganz anders offen meiner
meinung nach
es gibt hier auch so ein begriff der
nennt sich so news corp neuer schotte
das kann eigentlich jeder so sein und
das bekommt man auch tatsächlich öfters
mal gesagt es ist ein sehr ein land das
einen sehr willkommen heißt und das
merkt man nicht in jedem anderen land
der welt und auch vor allen dingen nicht
in england es gab ja schon ein
unabhängigkeitsreferendum sagen viele in
london und warum jetzt noch mal ein
zweites meiner meinung nach ist gerade
jetzt der moment eben weil es schon im
prinzip so viel chaos gibt und man ist
immer weiterhin abhängig von diesem
ganzen rexit chaos und was die britische
regierung daran und weitermachen wird
also ich würde sagen jetzt wirklich
super moment weil man kann jetzt ein
ganz neues land aufbauen mit anderen
werten und einer pro europäischen
ausrichtung das heißt du würdest den
schotten die unabhängigkeit wünsche ich
wünsche den schotten das und ich wünsche
mir dass denn ich bin hier zu hause und
für meine zukunft finde ich das super
ist die stadt in schottland mit den
meisten eu bürger
tanja bringt uns zu einem kleinen honig
laden in dem sie regelmäßig einkauft
betrieben von andy einem polen der hier
ausschließlich honig aus biologischem
anbau verkauft
ursprünglich kam er aus warschau
mittlerweile fühlt er sich wie tanja
hier aber wohler als irgendwo sonst auf
der welt
wenn mich jemand fragt ob ich zurück
nach polen gehen würde ich nein ich
bleibe zu hause das ist kaum zu hause
seine bienenstöcke hat andy außerhalb
von edinburgh
überall da wo landwirte ökologisch
wirtschaften auf diese weise wird sein
honig deutlich besser im geschmack und
seinen bienen bleiben die pestizide
erspart die idee nach schottland zu
ziehen hatte ihm sein großvater mit auf
den weg gegeben damals in polen als andy
noch ein kleiner junge war
die leute sind ehrlich hat er gesagt das
wetter ist furchtbar aber sie wissen wie
man trinkt es ist ein sehr freundliches
land
er meinte immer schottland sowie polen
ein bisschen unterschätzt als land aber
grund ehrliche leute
versteht er als pole den kampf vieler
schotten um unabhängigkeit deshalb
besonders gut
ja und ich denke es hat mit der
geschichte zu tun dass sie seit dem 17
jahrhundert ihre kultur und ihre
tradition verteidigen mussten und selbst
heute hast du eine regierungschefin
london der sie als nationalisten nur um
sie zu demütigen
ich denke dass sie schotten sich einfach
nicht anerkannt fühlen und dass sie das
ändern wollen
direkt hinter handys bienenstöcken liegt
fahrplan eine kleine stadt in der sich
seit vielen hundert jahren so wenig
verändert hat dass sie regelmäßig als
filmkulisse diente
im antik laden auf dem dorfplatz
verkauft bock beverage alte instrumente
die er vorher aufwendig reparieren lässt
bevor er sich hierhin zurückzog war bock
bei der mordkommission in glasgow und
später zuständig für die sicherheit der
queen
wann immer sie in val mora ihrem
schottischen sommerschloss war und
direkt gegenüber wohnte die mutter von
prinz william unser zukünftiger könig
der jahre enkel war kam immer mal zum
besuch vorbei aber immer nur ganz kurz
die königliche familie ist gewissermaßen
sein arbeitgeber geblieben mit dem
verkauf alter royaler memorabilien macht
bock bis heute die besten geschäfte als
realist ist ihm die unabhängigkeit ein
graus zusammen und ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob diese unabhängigkeit fans das
königshaus dann überhaupt noch haben
wollen
das wäre ein sehr trauriger tag
er hält nichts davon die dinge neu zu
erfinden
schon gar nicht ein ganzes land und
echte unabhängigkeit gebe es sowieso
nicht im leben erklärt er mir in seiner
wohnung über dem shop
wo er auf einer alten gitarre von paco
de lucia flamenco spielt wenn gerade mal
keine kunden kam
[Musik]
die schottische nationalpartei hält er
für kurzsichtig und naiv
außerdem wieder zurück in die das ist
aber doch keine unabhängigkeit
du bist doch nicht unabhängig wenn ihr
dann stattdessen brüssel sagt was du tun
sollst unabhängigkeit ist wenn du dann
wirklich alles selbst bestimmt
ich glaube sie haben das selbst nicht
ganz verstanden
ist das wirklich so ein widerspruch
unabhängig werden und dann doch wieder
der eu beitreten
die schottische nationalpartei will
schließlich genau das mitten in
edinburgh ist das büro von angus
robertson dem smp kandidaten der sich
vorgenommen hat eine der ganz wenigen
tory bastionen in schottland bei der
wahl anfang mai im sturm zu erobern
gewinnt er die wahl hier gewinnt die snp
das ganze land sagt er seine chancen
seien gut und dann gäbe es kein halten
mehr
london keine schottland nicht dauerhaft
vorenthalten was ist will die
unabhängigkeit auf den karten hügel
oberhalb der spa halb der stadt visuell
sich da eigentlich so sicher ist
zwei dinge haben den wunsch nach
unabhängigkeit klar befeuert wechselt
ist die personifizierung so bekommen wir
immer mehr
sie wollen der eu wieder beitreten aber
das hieße eine grenze mit ändern
das ist ja schon ein problem oder nicht
eine herausforderung und wir müssen
natürlich eine lösung dafür
das ist kein argument nicht selbst die
verantwortung zu übernehmen
aber die meisten waren die schottland
exportiert gehen nach england das ist
ein problem wäre wäre kanada kein
unabhängiges land weil es hauptsächlich
in die usa exportiert und die tatsache
dass im moment aber nicht von england
sind ist doch kein argument
wir wollen stattdessen wieder in den
größten markt ich habe es satt dass er
vom rest der welt abgeschnitten
wir wollen wieder mitspielen in der welt
und das tun was alle anderen nationen
auch tun uns selbst regieren noch nicht
regiert werden
ein unabhängiges schottland könnte sich
neu erfinden als ein sozialeres grüneres
land aber einfach wird das nicht
die union mit england ist über 300 jahre
alt und eine neue grenze die quer durch
die insel dinge macht vielen schatten
angst
die anderen wollen den aufbruch in die
unabhängigkeit seit dem brett jetzt mehr
denn je und so unvorstellbar eine
geteilte insel derzeit noch sein mag die
große mehrheit der jüngeren denkt
ernsthaft darüber nach ihren eigenen weg
zu gehen ohne engert die generation die
die zukunft bestimmen wird
[Musik]